Todd, Michael,
congratulations.
You've made it into the final
round of this competition,
which means that you're
both one step closer
to the title of Forged
in Fire champion
and that check for $10,000.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is the Kampilan.
Good luck.
We'll see you in five days.
MICHAEL: Feels really good to be
home and back in my home forge.
The Kampilan is
completely new to me.
Part of this is a
historical recreation,
so it's really important I
make it historically accurate.
All right, here's my new sword.
That's good.
I'm really nervous, because
it doesn't take much for this
to get messed up.
I feel I can do it, but I
just have to stay on task.
Looks pretty good.
My goal today was to
have a profiled sword.
That happened, and now
I'm a little further
ahead than I anticipated.
I'm beat.
TODD: Yesterday, I had
the up side of the motor
on the power hammer and
forged out my piece.
There you go.
That looks like the picture.
Today, I want to make sure I
get that thing all tapered,
narrowed down.
Getting the weight
off the blade,
and trying to thin that
down as a task in itself.
I hope I have it
thin enough for Doug.
Hopefully, it'll satisfy him.
It's getting a lot lighter.
Ready for heat treatment.
Quenching is a real
critical thing.
You don't want to
hear that little tink,
you know, that crack sound.
Oh.
[chuckling]
No cracks, no warps.
[inaudible] Yes, I'm
very happy with it.
Lord, thank you.
MICHAEL: Today I'm
going to cut spur
out of the tip of the blade.
All right, here we go.
There's a lot of bad things
that can happen here.
Taking a chisel to
any part of your blade
can result in
unfixable blemishes.
I'll take it.
Time for the heat treat.
Heat treat's the worst part
of any blade making process,
so I'm incredibly nervous.
Warping is the number
one concern I have.
When I dunk the
blade into that oil,
it's going to do what
it's going to do,
and there's nothing
I can do to stop it.
My gut wrenches.
Warp.
That sucks.
The thinner the
steel, the more tricky
it can be to get the heat treat
to go off without any issues.
But as I look at it, I like it.
Took kind of a scimitar
warp, adds character.
It doesn't go side to side, it
bows up, kind of like a katana.
That is the best word
you can possibly take on.
I will take it.
Today I think the plan
is probably eating sawdust.
I'm going to work
on that handle.
The way it's designed
is a little unusual.
The handle has protruding Y
that comes up towards your arm.
It looks like it would be
uncomfortable to yield,
but it's their blade.
I'm just making it.
Mark up the front guard,
and cut that one out.
I'm going to do the
top guard as one piece
and fit it to the handle.
Does kind of look
like a raptor, kinda.
It's not what I was
going for, but that's
what it turned out to be.
It's a dinosword.
[laughing]
I'm a little
apprehensive on testing.
If something
crucially goes wrong,
I won't have a blade to turn in.
So I'm going to leave this
to the judges to test.
Very nice.
It looks good.
It's a done deal.
This is my last day.
I feel pretty good.
Just need grind the tank,
finish off the handle
and just make stuff
pretty and sharp.
The handle material was
a big block of mahogany.
Mahogany is a traditional wood.
It's tough, it's rot resistant,
so I don't have too many
concerns about going into this.
Getting this handle put on and
that is the point of no return.
My only reservations with
this blade that it's hefty.
A lot of my research
points to the fact
that this is a heavy sword.
For the royal flare of the
sword, genuine human hair.
That is something that
was on these handles,
so it's merely for
historical accuracy.
And it's funny.
[chuckling]
Well, it's a Kampilan.
All right, gentlemen.
To test the sharpness
of your blades,
I'll be chopping through our
cat's cradle of rope here.
Todd, you're up first.
You ready?
I am.
[ropes snapping]
All right, Todd, this blade
has all the weight right here.
You know it's a weapon that's
designed to be used one
or two handed, but
controlling all
that forward weight
definitely puts
this as a two hand only sword.
It's a good looking piece,
and it definitely is a cutter.
Michael, you're up.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[ropes snapping]
Still a very heavy weapon.
I'd have zero
confidence swinging
this one handed that it
wouldn't get away from me.
But the weight
distribution on your blade
is further back, which
gave me quite a bit more
control to chop those ropes.
It's definitely a cutter,
so good job, nicely done.
Thank you
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
I'm going to take your Kampilan
and deliver lethal blows
on this big carcass.
Todd, you're up first.
You ready?
I sure am.
[blade slashing]
All right, Todd.
The swing over here almost cut
all the way, and, of course,
with an easy swing on the way
back, it cut the pig in half.
The Kampilan will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Michael, your turn.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[blade slashing]
All right, Mike.
So even though it
is a heavier blade,
it's counterbalance
allowed to wield going
forward and backward easily.
So it was an easy recovery
for the final chop.
Overall, your
Kampilan will kill.
Thank you.
HOST: Good job
All right, gentlemen.
To test the strength and
durability of your blade,
I'll be chopping into
this green bamboo.
Bamboo, it's hard stuff.
If you didn't harden your blade
right, there's a flaw in it,
this will tell it.
I am praying that
my edge holds up.
[blade chopping]
Whoa.
Yeah, I don't feel any
damage whatsoever on the edge.
It did a job on that
bamboo and it's clean.
Well done.
Thank you.
HOST: Michael, you ready?
Let's do it.
HOST: OK.
[blade chopping]
Well, I thought I saw
something, but it was just
bamboo stuck to your blade.
It's fine.
There's no damage there.
The blade hasn't
changed shape at all.
Good job, well done.
All right, bladesmiths,
from the moment you
guys lit those coal
forges until this moment,
you've put in a
lot of hard work.
There's been a lot of stress.
But in this arena
of competition,
there can only be one
Forged in Fire champion,
and that champion is Michael.
Congratulations, you are
the Forged in Fire champion.
Todd, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
Todd, this is what we judges
expect in the third round,
two beautiful blades,
equally matched.
But it comes down to
the finer details.
Your blade isn't
as well balanced
as that of your
opponents, and your design
and detail were not as strong.
So for those reasons,
we have to let you go.
Be proud of your work Todd,
because it was a close call.
But please surrender
your weapon.
TODD: I never thought
about making it this far.
This is the first
sword I've ever made.
I'm proud of what I did,
and it held up good.
I didn't think that I would
be capable of doing this.
You never know what kind
of strength you can find.
Michael, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother
[clapping]
All right what's going
on inside of there?
It is surreal.
Wasn't expected,
starting this competition
but a huge affirmation
of my skills.
Please present your
weapon to the judges.
MICHAEL: It's surreal.
It hasn't really set in yet.
All the years that I've put into
this hobby, this craft, and now
to be here and be
the Forged in Fire
champion, it's pretty amazing.